take big risks take that risk take risks
take risk taking risks think risks risk
taking risky take risk
hello believed nation today we're going
to talk about how you can take risks and
as always if you hear something that is
really relevant to you that you love the
message of please leave it in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
enjoy just because you're doing
something and you're successful at it
does not mean you have to continue doing
it and in some ways your willingness to
take big risks defines where your life
is going like like right now you know I
got a great house I got this cool stuff
like am I willing if the right
opportunity comes up am I willing to
leverage all that to bet again
that that your your willingness to take
those risks especially when you're young
is the difference between like I think
an average life and an extraordinary
life but I took this like big risk and
quit school I quit the one thing that I
was like there was like surefire and
went and became a model and it got
really bored really fast and didn't love
being a coat hanger and then I became an
actor which was like a coat hanger that
talks and and then and then I ultimately
like came full loop it came back around
and and by the way when you talk you're
generally not even speaking your own
words you're speaking somebody else's
words and trying to make it sound really
real and then I came full loop around
and and and started looking at
technology again I started getting
interested in technology and started
getting interested in engineering and
started really getting interested in
solving problems solving my own problems
and then solving other people's problems
and what the value of that is and so
whether it's it's technology or
philanthropy or actually even performing
or being an actor I started to make it
better
having problems and I think that that's
the that probably the single biggest
thing that as an angel investor I look
for in entrepreneurs is people who
genuinely want to solve a problem a real
problem a problem that exists not just
for themselves but sometimes just for
themselves and then it and then it then
it sort of turned into this wave effect
that solves other people's problems and
sometimes by trying to solve your own
problems you're solving everybody else's
problems because generally if you want
to affect the world you have to change
yourself first everybody tries to go out
and change the world by changing other
people and other things but the real way
to do it is by changing yourself and
sometimes making those really
uncomfortable choices to go up against
everyone in your life that you look up
to and take that risk to go be a model
or go do this thing that nobody else is
doing people told me that Black Swan was
an artistic risk a scary challenge to
try to perforate portray a professional
ballet dancer but it didn't feel like
courage or daring that drew me to it
I was so oblivious to my own limits that
I did things I was woefully unprepared
to do and so the very inexperienced that
in college had made me feel insecure and
made me want to play by other's rules
now was making me actually take risks I
didn't even realize were risks when
Darren asked me if I could do ballet I
told him that I was basically a
ballerina which by the way I
wholeheartedly believed when it quickly
became clear and preparing for the film
that I was maybe 15 years away from
being a ballerina it made me work a
million times harder and of course the
magic of cinema and body doubles helped
the final effect but the point is if I
had known my own limitations I never
would have taken the risk and the risk
led to one of my greatest artistic and
personal experiences and that I not only
felt completely free I also met my
husband during filming when I visited
students I also tell them that the
greatest risk they take is not taking
one which by the way of mr. Marteen has
taught me that and I use it to this day
anytime I feel that should I I feel
nervous
right now and I take the risk and for
all the students for all the teachers
and followed educators here we have to
take risk if we don't take that risk I
go back to it it's the biggest risk that
we take you will have many many many
opportunity opportunities to reinvent
yourself and so you know so I think you
know it's worthwhile taking risks I'm
trying to do something you're really you
know excited by if the first attempt you
don't do it you know you can try again
and you know things tend to work out in
the long run in Silicon Valley you know
you know parties and so many people
start up with companies starting up a
company and even having failed you can
wear it like a badge of honor right and
I think it's important you know
culturally you know risk is rewarded I
remember when I started working at
Google you know I if I went and you know
people were discussing ideas to other
people who heard the ideas try to build
on those ideas they encourage you so
it's a culture of optimism it's a
culture of risk-taking and I think
that's really important so I think that
you have to take risks all the time if
you don't do that you don't move forward
we are trying to be too conservative in
the way that you think life and the
results is that nobody voice ought to
say I don't agree with this I agree with
that so we have to push somehow our our
individuality to make sure that our
voice can be heard there was one time
and I don't even remember it might have
been the Fantastic Four some other book
we had a story that I thought wasn't
that good but we were stuck with it we
had to send it out there was the due
date I didn't have time to do it over
and on the cover I wrote a little note
something I don't remember the exact
words but something like hey kids I've
got to admit this isn't the best story
we've ever done but we've given you so
many good ones before we think you owe
it to us to buy this one also everybody
thought I was crazy you know that books
sold better than most of the others of
that period and I got a ton of mail
saying you
guys are great nobody else were written
anything like that
I don't know nowadays a rejection is
part of your everyday life so I think a
lot of business and doing things is just
the idea of having resilience alright I
ask y'all a question if your little five
year old comes to you with a painting
from school what are you going to say
good absolutely the worst thing you can
say because what you do by saying good
job is you teach a child but please
others rather please themselves what you
might want to say is tell me about the
painting and why did you do it but I
think I'm producing I don't know if
today people are risk takers they want a
lot of attaboys you have to get it from
within sooner or later so I'm not sure
guy amplify it a little bit absolutely
please Here I am I'm at USC and it's
really not complicated I saw these
people in line
Xerox ooh what a discovery if they're
Xerox in at USC why wouldn't they Xerox
at Santa Barbara was this such research
I didn't invent the Xerox machine they
were just inline xeroxing and it at one
point I mean all the customers could see
I had all the customers in line my old
workers could see how much money I was
taking it and I was in every we expanded
every College in America what always
baffled me is why I didn't have more
people across the street competing with
me and I think even back then you were
Christic we were risk takers but look
back on your grandparents if your
grandparents had seen that I had
something good with customers line do
you think they would have been out there
competing with me in a heartbeat so I'm
not sure risk-taking is as rewarded as
it should be you had pretty ambitious
sales targets all you're going to be
able to hit those you never know until
the last minute you know the objective
of when you make a long-term plan is not
to make sure from the beginning that
you're going to hit them because if you
are sure from the beginning going to hit
all your targets that when your targets
are conservative that's the only way you
can be sure so you want to maintain
certain stretched inside the company and
being innovative and creative and
finding new products and new solutions
in order to hit the target
so it's risky but that's the price to
pay for development almost any
accomplishment in the history of the
world has come at the hands of people
who've taken risk people who are willing
to push the envelope people who are
willing to explore the unknown even if
you go and you look in the Bible you
know that the people that are held up as
a heroes they're not the ones who were
sitting in their tent under an olive
tree you know were people who are going
out there doing start and you know the
key thing about taking risk is is
learning you know and if something
doesn't work out learn from it and then
you're able to move further we have to
always recognize that you know knowledge
frequently comes at a price you know
Thomas Edison said you know 999 ways
that a light bulb did not not work right
you know many of us are familiar with
the cleaning formula 409 why do they
call it that the first floor hundred
Nate didn't work you know but you know
you just put these things into
perspective and you learn from them
Walter dandy the great neurosurgeon at
Johns Hopkins many decades ago was the
first one to do operations on the
posterior fossa the back part of the
brain no one thought it could be done
first thirteen patients all died now can
you imagine how devastating that was I
can't even imagine what he said to the
fourteenth patient when they said how
they have a thirteen do you know but but
the fact of the matter is we now are
able to do that operation routinely and
safely I did one last week and so you
know we just have to put all these
things in perspective and recognize that
we will never make progress unless we're
willing to take risk but we have to take
them in an appropriate fashion right
because you know there there's a large
group of people who never get anywhere
because they're afraid to take a risk
there's another group of people we'll
never get anywhere because they take too
many of the wrong dress they're always
getting not
to the pond so that's where this
tremendous brain comes in where you are
able to analyze your appropriate shoes
just thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
you thought of the video what was your
favorite clip and why how are you taking
risks in your business leaving the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to William Chilton William
thank you so much for picking up a
couple of my book your one word and for
posting the picture I love it man and
really really appreciate it so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon